Haiti the poorest country in the Western
Hemisphere ravaged by an earthquake in
2010 most in this Caribbean outpost are
living in darkness globally 20% of
people don't have access to electricity
in Haiti it's 75 percent sleep ect
blah blah deposit mom we clear as he
clear
impoverished and without alternatives
Haiti's become a testing ground for a
DIY power system that could help bring
electricity to the 1.3 billion people
worldwide who currently have none it's
one of many tentative steps toward a
future where solar energy will plan ever
larger role in powering the planet in
one hour the Sun provides the equivalent
amount of energy that the entire world
uses in a year this is the story of the
Solar pioneers and the technology they
hope will shape the future
for me leave them below me
I'm lovin her laughs did you for that
deal single mum Madeline has never had
access to electricity today that's going
to change until now she's used kerosene
to feed lamps spending $10 a month but
her homes about to be hooked up to a
groundbreaking energy system that will
light her home for just one dollar 50 a
month
I love history leg recipe we need a food
system estamos aqui energy Fergie Nia
has to give up the table in court after
geology everybody's gonna go on to bring
us at we will give warm em to you this
inequality the country's limited
national grid hadn't made it to the town
of leis Anglais
but this town's generating its own
electricity in a groundbreaking power
system that could provide a template for
towns all across the developing world
the system's been pioneered by allison
archambault
NGO earthspark international it's one of
only a handful of towns across the world
that are 100% powered by solar energy
and available with electricity 24 hours
a day with smart meters that enable
people to pay as you go and top-up their
meter and change their access to
electricity to meet their needs this
system provides enough energy for this
community's current needs from lighting
people's homes to powering the town's
mill it's a model that could be the
first step on the energy ladder for many
others in the developing world there's
incredible opportunity for innovation in
these places that lack infrastructure so
when you have no incumbent system it's
actually a wonderful opportunity to
build a better system that's something
good for this town and lays Anglais
it's good for other towns in Haiti and
it's also replicable in other places
around the world
we're really trying to share this
information and build the models that
really can spin-off in scale global
electricity demand is projected to grow
by almost eighty percent over the next
25 years with developing countries
accounting for the bulk of the increase
past increases in energy supply have
relied largely on fossil fuels which in
many situations still provide the
cheapest options but they come with an
obvious environmental cost we're the
first generation to feel the impact of
climate change or the last generation
they can do something about it we only
get one home we only get one planet
there's a growing pressure to phase out
fossil fuels and deliver cleaner energy
a cause being championed by global
organizations like Richard Branson's
carbon war room I have a slogan don't
don't dig up the dead anything that
comes from under the ground is creating
this blanket around the earth and that
is going to inevitably heat it up to
potentially a very dangerous level so
what we need to do is power the world by
fuels that are created above the ground
and I obviously have a much bigger
carbon footprint than most people the
desire to travel is just one example of
the contradiction between the energy
demands of the rich world and concerns
about the carbon emissions that result
all the more reason for those who profit
to take a lead in finding ways to meet
those demands with clean renewable
energy there's a lot of people trying to
resist the move to clean energies and
they're doing it because they don't
necessarily believe in global warming or
they want to protect the oil and the
coal industries they're fighting for
their livelihoods
the problem is that implementing an
entirely new renewable infrastructure
isn't easy especially in countries that
are heavily reliant on oil coal and gas
Coleman Alabama is home to Apple steel
all of this is very high intense power
consumption equipment if the power goes
out in this facility it costs its
company ten thousand dollars an hour
this is a factory where metal meets
muscle but behind this deep south
manufacturing plant lies a surprise it's
the world's first off-grid solar powered
industrial Factory the visionary behind
this self-generating energy system is
Chuck Boggs from Ace LLC solar the coal
oil lobbyists all said it couldn't be
done even the Renewable people said it
couldn't be done I searched and searched
and finally found electrical engineer
that thought about it and he said I
think we can do it Chuck and here is the
result this manufacturing plant is now
generating its own electricity so it's
no longer reliant upon the grid it
expects not just to cut its carbon
emissions but to cut its energy bills to
tax incentive schemes are helping
businesses like Apple steel to take the
plunge but long-term subsidies may not
be necessary
the prices of fossil fuels like oil coal
and gas fluctuate but until recently
they've all been a far cheaper option to
solar but Solar is catching up fast
year-on-year solar power production is
getting exponentially cheaper price
means nothing without performance and
one of the greatest challenges facing
solar pioneers is how to make hay when
the Sun isn't shining now one man
believes he's found a revolutionary way
to store solar energy the issue with
existing batteries is that they saw ok
they're really horrible Tesla founder
Elon Musk has developed a new
lithium-ion battery technology that's
being rolled out as a consumer product
you can actually go if you want
completely off grid you can take your
solar panels charge the battery packs
and that's and that's all you use
powering homes is a starting point but
by releasing this video presentation to
the world Musk's company was
highlighting much more than the launch
of a new product so we could power a
small city and we can keep going here in
a performance tailored for a mass
audience
his bold claims pointed to a reinvention
of the way we power the world this is
actually within the power of humanity to
do it we have done things like this
before still in its infancy
this battery technology already enables
upheld still to run its operation day or
night a few years ago this would not
have been possible we collaborated with
Tesla's engineering and between their
battery technology and our integration
we're able to capture energy into these
batteries to run our facility for 6
hours in spite of all the recent
progress solar still only produces 1% of
global electricity to become a serious
player it needs another game-changing
logical leap
one scientist in Oxford England thinks
he may have the answer in an air locked
laboratory tests are being carried out
on a new material that could be far more
effective at capturing energy and
traditional silicon solar panels so this
is a solution that we call Brad sky it's
an extremely effective solar absorber
bulky existing solar panels convert
around 20% of light into electricity as
it passes through in the lab they can
achieve the same results with this new
super thin material this material is
something on the order of several
thousand times more effective at
converting photons into electrons than
silicon as a result of that it can be
made very thin in fact it's so thin it's
only about two thousand angstroms in
thickness
that makes it transparent when applied
to glass so we have a very thin coating
on this conventional piece of glass done
on this equipment and in under a minute
we've produced effectively a
photovoltaic solar panel just combining
perovskite with traditional silicon
panels has already been proven to nearly
double their output
it's an early indication of the
potential for products using parov skite
to be highly efficient lightweight and
cost-effective we have a ways to go
before we can actually truly change the
world but we're on that note in time it
represents something that's a little
more efficient and far less expensive if
a technology like this can make the jump
from the lab to the mass-market glass
buildings could generate electricity in
an entirely new way with less dependence
on the grid the economics of the energy
industry could be transformed to
the energy industry is the largest
industry in the world and imagine
changing where the control of that grid
occurs no longer is in the large
electricity energy generating companies
but it becomes distribute amongst
communities and even individuals back in
Haiti the lights are about to be
switched on in Madeline's house velcome
cotton optional common pathway home be
ok ponte di coke watanabe-san g open by
the FMV
fossil fuels have served the world's
energy needs for centuries but solar
technology is now on the brink of being
properly competitive it's the start of a
long journey but today homes in Haiti
and factories in Alabama are beginning
to show the potential of a different
energy path one that's clean renewable
and urgently needed
you